ziemlich keller aus frankfurt am main
ist auf der suche
der 26-jährige hofft eine partnerin zu
finden im internet online dating
plattformen sind längst etabliert
eine der weltweit bekanntesten ist
kinder von facebook profil der user
werden vorname alter fotos und
gemeinsame interessen angezeigt anhand
dieser wenigen informationen entscheidet
der user ob er interesse hat oder nicht
wer mich kennt nutzt eine ähnliche app
minder funktioniert nach demselben
prinzip
die app richtet sich aber ausschließlich
an eine zielgruppe muslime ich bin auf
der suche nach einer ernsthaften
beziehung durch minder erhoffe ich mir
eine partnerin zu finden
langfristig gesehen die die selben
interessen b ist erteilt fake accounts
haben es hier schwerer bei linda werden
alle profile im vorfeld auf echtheit
geprüft
auf einem religiosität barometer gibt
der nutzer auskunft wie gläubig er ist
auch die glaubensrichtung kann
eingetragen werden rund 20.000 user aus
nordamerika und großbritannien suchen
bereits über minder seit august ist die
app auch in deutschland erhältlich
auf die idee kam der us-amerikaner aaron
rodgers ada aus washington dc
der unternehmer wollte seinen freunden
helfen
viele leute sind zu mir gekommen und
haben mich gefragt wo sie anständige
muslime zu monaten finden können
besonders frauen meinten es sei sehr
schwer anständige muslimischen männer
hier in amerika ziehen
also dachte ich vielleicht kann hier die
technik helfen eheschließungen unter
muslimischen paaren darüber forsch der
erziehungswissenschaftler ahmet toprak
er weiß wieso menschen lieber einen
partner mit derselben religion suchen
das problem besteht darin dass bei der
kindererziehung kann sich nicht einigen
können nach welche vorstellungen die
kinder erzogen werden soll
und der großteil sagt auch im vorfeld
okay dann lieber doch aus meiner
religion dann weiß ich woran ich bin
dann muss ich mich mit dem partner nicht
damit auseinandersetzen nach welcher
vorstellung die er zum die kinder
vonstatten
auch andere religionsgruppen suchen die
liebe in der digitalen welt auf jake
finden sich jüdische paare und das schon
seit fast 20 jahren
aktuell besuchen die website monatlich
rund 280.000 user
christen können gleichgesinnte partner
über christen mindere finden
mehr als 300.000 nutzer haben sich seit
2004 registriert beide plattformen
erlauben auch die suche nach
gleichgeschlechtlichen partnern
religions- spezifische dating seiten
verzeichnen wachsende nutzerzahlen
generell findet die partnersuche immer
häufiger online statt
niebel hat sich verändert vor allem was
unser verständnis von je 1 geht es ist
nicht mehr nur eine partnerschaft
sondern der versuch seinen
seelenverwandten zu finden
deswegen glaube ich dass dating apps die
zukunft sind weil sie es ermöglichen
unseren horizont zu erweitern und mehr
potenzielle partner kennenzulernen
keller hofft lediglich auf eine
langjährige beziehung
ich halte es für sehr unrealistisch die
frau des lebens über eine dating app zu
finden
dafür bin ich so romantisch als dass ich
mir erhoffe auf einem bildschirm auf dem
handy
die frau ministeriums angezeigt zu
bekommen eine nüchterne sicht trotzdem
die suche geht auch für sehr mich keles
weiter und häufig kommt es anders als
man denkt